bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors le niger qui va
connaître pour la première fois de son
histoire une alternance entre deux
présidents élus beaucoup d'espoir donc
dans cette élection
oui j'ai fait mais comme vous l'avez dit
c'est beaucoup d'espoir parce que c'est
la première alternance en plus du tout
certaine indépendance de l'indépendance
à nous le public en dépit 1958 et la
démocratie est alité dans les années 90
mais c'est la première fois qu'un
président de l'upg et du mandat et le
transmet elle notre président élu par la
population
d'un côté comme marc houle a dit hier le
président plein qui viennent savard
confort et consolider la démocratie est
vraiment la rejeter ces élections
surtout quand voici qu il passe les
autres avec la tentation des mandats et
les non dits
vous êtes à niamey est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire comment s'est déroulée
la journée d'hier dans la capitale
globalement que ce soit de la capitale
ouvert à l'intérieur du pays ne s'est
déroulée sans incident majeur
à part quelques manquements comment les
préparations dans certains bureaux de
vote étaient maîtres locaux
il n'y a pas eu d'incident majeur sa
visite intervient dans le contexte de la
pandémie ducobu 17 mais surtout surtout
l'insécurité la sélectivité et on
s'attendait en redouter des attaques
terroristes que s'asseoir dans l'est du
pays à l'extrême est à la frontière avec
le tchad le nigérian surtout ceux ci
beauvoir ou de la partie ouest nord du
pays à la frontière avec le mali où il
ya deux groupes terroristes comme l'état
islamique comme aqmi qui sévit
vraiment il ya quelques jours aussi à la
veille des élections locales le 13
décembre il y avait eu une attaque à
toulouse et à la libye et avec le
presque 24 morts il n'y avait pas plus
le scrutin n'a pas pu se tenir
mais cette fois globalement tout s'est
tenue dans le calme de la sérénité
surtout ici à niamey où les observateurs
ont relevé une alliance de nigériens
iront se sentait vraiment quelle
indigènes sont conscients du ciel de
régal de l'année installés ou presque le
double alors mamadou issoufou a choisi
de ne pas se représenter il a fait deux
mandats à la tête du niger quel bilan
peut-on faire de ces années une
gouvernance le bilan c'est un bilan
contrasté déjà sur le plan démocratique
le fait qu'il passe le relais le
respecte les termes de la constitution
les temps de la construction est une
grande avancée
maintenant c'est au plein un thème qui a
fait un problème d'offre le président
issoufou est venu vous pouvoir en 2011
avec un ambitieux programme qu'on
appelle programme vu leurs émissions
c'était en 2000 ans quelques mois après
sur les actionnaires de suture le niger
a subi les premières attaques parce que
vous savez avec la station au ahly lui
qui a dégénéré le marais frontalier du
niger et à l'incitation au mali qui a
dégénéré le mali est frontalier du niger
il ya beaucoup investi la station au
nigeria du coup tout son programme de
lutte contre la pauvreté d'améliorer
l'éducation est tombé presque à l'eau
puisqu'il a fallu dégager des
investissements pour les ailes les
canaliser vers est et les orienter vers
la prise en charge des questions
sécuritaires et la famille renforcer
l'armée il n'a pas dû vraiment la poisse
il dispose et qui peut-être ce qui a
fait qu'ils avaient pas eu de grandes
avancées en terme d'indicateurs sociaux
économiques
pour ça que l'église elle continue à
rester internée amateurs déplacement
idéaliste développement humain des
nations unies hegel et la situation
socioéconomique les jeunes on a vraiment
senti est une avancée dans l'erreur de
leur vécu quotidien
justement du fait que le programme du
président a été orienté vers la nouvelle
priorité qui est la prise en charge de
la question sécuritaire alors vous
disiez ans le niger à dernier au niveau
de l'idée h on sait que plus de la
moitié de la population vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté que devra faire celui
qui prendra la tête du niger pour
redistribuer de manière juste et
équitable les richesses du pays
on l'a vu déjà quand est on l'a vu déjà
de leur programme de campagne tout le
monde sait ce qu'il faut faire et faut
investir de l'agriculture il faut
investir dans les secteurs sociaux il
faut investir l'éducation maintenant le
gros problème est le constable la
reddition de celui qui va vers yves il
faut que la ch'ti la question ce qu'il
se passe
invisible c'est vrai jusqu'à présent le
niger a pu c'est maintenant comme no2
stabilité et à part des territoires qui
empêcha et qui échappent au contrôle de
l'état
mais les ménages sont criants beauvoir
apprentis toujours à frapper al qaïda
aussi l'état islamique vous a vu
récemment il y avait même si à cinquante
kilomètres de niamey qui avaient ils
attaquent de cours et dont il lui nous
rappelle développement 5
il y aura sept qui sont sécuritaires il
ya des placements des places en cuir à
l'hésitation qui m'a aidé et aide encore
plus drastique il y aura une paille à
voilà la somme des cols les
investissements dans les secteurs
sociaux techniques a pas là donc il ya
plusieurs programmes qui ont été menées
avec l'aide des patelins des barres de
fortes mais qu'il s'agissait de
quelqu'un ça représenterait venus et la
question sécuritaire qui va prendre le
bus
il faut que cette citation sécurité soit
vraiment régler pour que le pays puisse
consacrer d'immenses ressources là où il
ya il y en a le besoin à dire de
l'éducation et les autres aboubakar la
barma merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que
rédacteur en chef d'actes univers merci
à vous